today's topic it's a video straight out
of japan i just want to start this off
by saying that we are all different and
all of our differences are beautiful
so some differences are more beautiful
than others
[Music]
referr
is right
corner
[Music]
is that when you see people from
different countries try to speak a
different language
because they're the way that they
pronounce things come from such a
different place yes they've been
throwing people off for example when you
ask english people to go say like arabic
words or like people
spanish words yes they can't do it go
for it tacos
nicaragua
por favor
gagnon no gang gagnon
gagnon [ __ ] out of here so but i'm not a
lot i stumbled on this video japanese
people tried to sing this word and i was
crying
you ever seen french people try to say
english words of course
tables the thing
just think that it's like yeah we have
different shapes
more
[Music]
he threw three free throws oh they
[ __ ] up they [ __ ] up
so they they just [ __ ] up what did he
say [ __ ]
he said what he could that's what he
said he threw three three throws
three three three please
if i was if i was japanese i would have
said it just like that because i thought
i get these [ __ ] i hate it yes
you is how am i hitting you hating
that's funny
he dreams
[Music]
leprechaun music
oh wow
come on let me let me put on my iron
hoodie just to support my leprechauns
this [ __ ] said leprechauns you
think oh my god
three free throws the lady
all right that's offended i'm sorry
y'all is it offensive yeah if you're
irish and you felt offended by her
deadline
hey sorry people if you're from ireland
that are looking at us and watching us
yo next next guinness is on us all right
psych
irish people can drink so they'd be like
[ __ ] you gotta give me three
is
i don't know what the hell you've been
told but that's a goddamn refrigerator
man this man got hit by a bus got
reincarnated to an isekai where he's a
japanese person who can say english
words this man has been training for
this day like it's an rpg level 10
english skills shout out to my man he
said refrigerators
[Music]
he's a refrigerator were you about to
say reference because
is that what you said
you know what kills me is the way that
the end of works yeah like they take me
like they got it
[Music]
necessary
hey man i like nestle too bro nestle
cereal is my favorite
sai martini martini
okay
i appreciate you because he got the
first half right he wants simon
martinez
simultaneously
[Applause]
this [ __ ] is winging him he's
like okay simultaneously
shimuru
turner
english is a it's a language of beat
sometimes [ __ ] don't make sense in
english like you have rules but you
don't really have rules
like it's crazy it's just like
read read lead lead same way to write
the word i gotta figure out as i read my
sentence how to [ __ ] say it
no
people i know english doesn't make a lot
of sense in some parts because
we speak the language that makes the
least amount of sense
french
yes
french rules are just there to be bougie
frank and they actually the answer they
made it extra hard so that we know
do you know that how to make a
difference oh you don't know how to
speak proper french you're not educated
yes so that's rules are stupid
i mean i know [ __ ] who've been
speaking their whole lives you asked
them to write they're like oh [ __ ] it
mama yeah but my french is my first
language
tell them it's easier to write in
english
there's a bunch of people always lie to
mine i really want to learn french
watching you good [ __ ] looks
long man
i will agree
when necessary
unnecessary
[Music]
was [ __ ] up but she went unnecessary
yeah [ __ ] it up
unnecessary
shout out to you my lady yes my girl
she shares she shares visa
she's her
she's hard no
she's [ __ ]
she said she said man [ __ ] she's
shore
is that a little mermaid selling on
seashells
that's stupid sorry oh
my gosh i apologize
don't you apologize for what you're
sorry about [ __ ] cause i was stupid
that's yeah let's all be stupid right
now we having to laugh laugh at
ourselves laugh at that i'm talking
about the mermaid [ __ ]
that was stupid
is that the little barbarian
[Applause]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] yeah this man this guy did you
not notice there's a couple women that
appear behind him when you are an isekai
character when you are the emcee the
main character the protagonist yeah
you'll be killing it and women just
start appearing you know the harem yeah
the herald women
that's him yeah they just oh she says
what now shout out to him bro he killed
him vincent brought vengeance very very
mentally vincent verved
yes very behind
oh
yo shout out to him for making a
comeback because he's been getting
[ __ ] up by these ones but he killed it
all right let's go you already know this
[ __ ] about to nail it who are
they sent aboard the penguin johnson
very pension pantry
[Music]
he made you lie if you laugh and you
have fun you better like this [ __ ]
video and go to hell with us
okay
be sent for the pink ken jensen very
pension pantry vegementary
oh you know how you i should have known
he [ __ ] up because he started with
cool
hey man shout out to these guys shout
out to them all right if any of you guys
get mad and want to see vengeance on
this listen understand that these are
just jokes but then again
english is is it makes no and i said it
before it makes no sense sometimes i
gotta sound words i gotta look at words
in my head and be like
what's the beat on that word again look
i got it you know we need to normalize
we need to normalize failure and we need
to normalize people trying it's okay to
just be like
you [ __ ] it up and it's okay it's okay
and and keep [ __ ] up and it might be
funny we might not laugh but you should
keep going like i would never look at
these people and try to discourage them
from speaking english or if they wanted
help that'd be something like yeah let's
talk right because if i knew people like
me were struggling but it's not going to
be the fact sometimes when you
mispronounce things it's hilarious
there's something funny when you have
your native tongue and people try to say
certain words you know it's off like for
you in your head it throws you off
because you've heard that word a million
times one way they come in they say
differently it's funny the first time i
heard a spanish person saying
valentine's day i died when i heard a
mexican be like hey yeah we're uh
lincolnshire meant by knowing we're
taking her out to valentine's day i was
like bro you can't say valentine's i was
crying okay but those cultural
differences not only to inform us like
about other people's cultural
experiences but
they can be [ __ ] funny i remember
when i was a kid i was in cuba yeah i
was nine years old and we were in uh
horseback riding right it's my mom my
sister you know you came for money
somebody said horseback riding yeah but
in cuba true not here true [ __ ] you mean
okay hey listen i'm feeling a cool sign
though if you guys are on any dating
apps and the [ __ ] says she's into
equestrian
that she come from money okay she come
for money and she'll freak carry off
so
you see the dick or the horse anyways
they'd be on saddles all day anyways all
right oh that's the society
i'm there and i'm glad i'm like oh my
mother galdon which is old mom look a
cow there's a bunch of cows in the
pasture and and those cubans i was like
oh what did you say uh is that in french
yeah that's cow oh in spanish is vaca
all right well in french it's vash
bash
vash
like you could see them form their lid
like no no you're going too far
bash
no don't do it like that don't do it
bash they couldn't say bash you could
all these years they said vodka what's
the difference between spanish people
from spain and from latin america
in the speaking yeah
you ever heard a spanish rapper from
spain that is the gayest [ __ ] i you
will ever hear the french people from
spain the the the spanish people from
france from the spanish people from
spain
are like the french people from france
they have a little
yeah
but at least the french from french
sounds really nice i think the spanish
from spain it's not bad
but it sounds stupid in hip-hop
the french people is when they insult
you that it sounds like
i'm just talking about phonetically but
that but the but the way the the well
i'm always ready to hit on the french i
don't mind personally but the spanish it
is the s there's something about a list
is that something about a lispy sound in
a rap song it's like considering how
like anti-gay rap is yeah it's so funny
about hearing like
so i'm talking about a hard [ __ ] trying
to talk about i sell drugs i shoot guns
you're like
you already know how much of a gank
value
you can't it doesn't work
right but
spanish is a beautiful language when you
hear them speak it's still wonderful but
a rap it sounds stupid so all those
little differences in how people talk
fascinates me you know that's really
weird portuguese love them love my
portuguese people love my brazilians
sorry when you called my favorite music
genre hip hop hippie hoppy i'm gonna
laugh at your face
that's that's resilience
yes portuguese
www
hey listen to hackers
to vote do you listen to music i love to
listen to haircuts
or instead of records yeah
yeah yeah yeah your hug
but anyways i'm not gonna get too deep
into it hey man we love languages what'd
you guys think about this video maybe
you thought it was too inappropriate but
it was we had a good time did y'all have
a good time and you laughed if you laugh
and you had fun you better like this
[ __ ] video and go to hell with us
okay
they're going to hell with us